I think we have to look at what
situation this country would be in if we
hadn't acted people were facing fuel
bills energy bills of up to six thousand
pounds we had very high inflation
expectations and an economic slowdown
and what we've done is we've taken
decisive action first of all to make
sure that nobody is paying more than a
typical fuel bill of two thousand five
hundred pounds that will come in this
Saturday but also to reduce our tax
burden to make sure we grow the economy
and also curb inflation and that's so
important it's a difficult time we're
facing a global economic crisis brought
about by Putin's war in Ukraine and what
was right is that Britain took decisive
action to help people get through what
is going to be a difficult winter it's
incredible to suggest that the mini
Budget on Friday didn't have an impact
on what has happened over the last few
days are you really suggesting that well
the biggest measure in the mini budget
was the support we have given to people
on their energy bills and it was
absolutely right that we gave that
support because without that support
people would be facing High fuel bills
this winter I was worried about people
struggling to eat their homes but also
we but also also we would have seen
businesses like pubs go out of business
so the it was the right decision to take
and we need to continue to make sure we
deliver the economic growth that we
deliver the jobs and opportunities and
that is the long-term future that we
have set out just on delivery then
um we're being told already that
government departments are looking for
efficiencies they're being told to look
for efficiencies where on Earth are
those efficiencies going to come from
it's absolutely right that we always
need to get value for taxpayers money
you know every pound that we take from
somebody is a pound they could be
spending on their you know future on
there you know what they need to support
themselves so it's right that we get
value for money and I'm always making
sure that we deliver that we're from
well there are always ways that we can
organize things more efficiently but
what I want to make sure is taxpayer
money is focused on Frontline services
on getting our GP appointments making
sure people can get to see a doctor
making sure we deliver on our road
projects all of those things that people
rely on us for but there are plenty of
areas where the government can become
more efficient
well not not at the moment we're
continually reviewing to make sure we're
getting good value for money and I think
that's what taxpayers expect